good morning everyone thank you for
being with us today
I feel like this is going to piss me off
this is gonna piss you off I think so
I think not oh no I mean I know how much
you love the police so yeah more love
for the police on the first day of
employment at the sheriff's office and
we hire once a month
I meet with the men and women and I said
I expect you to be honest
ethical and moral all the time
I expect you to treat people like you'd
want your mother treated
and if you do that you'll have a
wonderful career here
and then I go on to explain that
you know if you work for a fast food
restaurant
and they catch you sliding pizzas out
the back door to their friends
they will terminate your employment and
run you off
but there's a difference
if we find you violating the law at the
Sheriff's Office where we will also
terminate your employment but we will
lock you up in the county jail
we're held to a higher standard
you can't police a community
if you don't hold yourself to a higher
standard than you expect of the people
from the community
you got me [ __ ] up
you thought I was going to piss you off
I thought you was about why would you
think that I generally [ __ ] you do
[Laughter]
rewriting history so with that being
said that being said uh we're gonna keep
playing the video yeah so think about
this
we're off to a good start we're off to a
good start I'm gonna give you a hundred
let's see if we're gonna maintain that
good start
that being said
then I look at them and I say do you
understand what I said and I have them
all say yes sir I understand
these folks forgot
why the [ __ ] is employee picture look
like this
I'm not going on what the [ __ ] is this
you remember when they had a picture of
the edge was cool if I brought something
like that to my mom I get my ass what my
dude
I like how you pulled out those [ __ ]
school pictures like a like like a
parent too
this is my child here he graduated 10
years ago [ __ ] laude
he pulled that [ __ ] out
they forgot what they were taught
they obviously didn't pay any attention
to my warning
and as a result we locked these three
deputies up
on Friday night
and here's how it started ooh Story Time
these three folks
we're on our crime suppression team
we were receiving complaints
and actually fears of gang activity and
narcotics activity in a community and
they were sent there to try to keep the
community safe
stop the narcotics dealing
and as a result
break up the gang activity
while patrolling in the Winter Haven or
the Central District area They Came Upon
a suspect who ran a red light
John rosinski who has been with us for
about three and a half years
stopped the vehicle
he was backed up by Jamal Lawson
and Garrett cook
when they stopped they asked for
permission to search the vehicle which
was denied which is traditionally what
our suspects do we call it canine the
canine did a search and alerted to drugs
they searched the vehicle and they found
in the trunk of the vehicle marijuana
and Alprazolam control substances
so they arrested the suspect
and in the suspect's pocket it was a
female she had more marijuana in small
quantities
and
723 dollars
when they rode in their affidavit to put
her in jail
and John rosinski was the arresting
deputy
they wrote that They seized a large
quantity of cash
so they wrote it and they arrest
affidavit and they also wrote it in
their initial report
so this was on the 21st of December they
take the suspect to jail they have a day
off they come back to work on the 23rd
3rd of December
where John writes his report and he
processes evidence and he puts several
pieces of evidence
into property and evidence
but they don't put any cash
any money into property and evidence how
much money did she have 723 Merry
Christmas [ __ ] that's it you got
caught for 723 dollars
what the three of them talk about on the
23rd is uh oh the money's missing
they counted it all three of them at
some point in time counted the money and
determined it was 723 dollars
and then I'll fast forward to the
investigation
rosinski said Lawson had the money
Lawson said he didn't have the money
resist he had the money and Garrett cook
said I never had the money but they all
admitted counting the money
so
they decided on the 23rd of December
we've really got a problem here
we're missing money we've lost the 723
dollars
they decided at that point what they
would do is they would all kick in
and replace the money
which is inappropriate by the way
but they never did
and they did not go to their supervisor
and say we lost the money
so time goes on
rosinski even has a conversation
and says you know I'm afraid before this
is over with I'm going to get arrested
for theft
so they still do nothing
now let's Advance into March when our
suspects felony charges are reduced to
misdemeanor possession of marijuana
once that happens
our suspect calls property and evidence
and said hey I'd like to have my cell
phone and my money back
she said it was somewhere under 730
dollars she didn't know exactly how much
exactly how much
property and evidence refers her back to
the district and to the supervisors
where the event occurred
she calls and talks to what we call the
rid Regional intake Detective
that detective was filling in actually
for the red detective and she said look
I would like my money back
so he looks he pulls up the reports and
he says we'll get back to you
he calls rosinski and says
um I don't see anybody here
rosinski gets panicked
rosinski starts talking to his buddies
and I'm giving you the 30 000 foot view
because at the and you can see in in the
press release they have different
versions of this conversation
in the meantime rosinski also calls down
to p e property and evidence
the property and evidence lady goes um
no there's no mention of any money in
any of that property and evidence that
was that was seized and ultimately we
have but the property and evidence lady
went forward and searched all around to
see if maybe a piece of evidence got
lugged by mistake under the wrong case
number and she found none
and then rosinski says
when he called the lady at peony says
she said he said call me back on my on
your personal cell phone so they had
this conversation and he said did
anybody hear you talking to me just
forget this conversation occurred
she hangs the phone up and she says to
herself self
that doesn't sound right I ain't about
to lose my job for the money
my emotions are going everywhere with
this story no no me I'm invested why did
you stop I'm on episode two season three
no invested I'm saying it's all over the
place at first I was like yeah they're
[ __ ] corrupt get them then I found
out it was 723 I'm like do I really give
a [ __ ] and they didn't really steal it
from what they say foreign
cops
for my [ __ ] cops free free my cops
solinsky and then I find out the reason
why they got the money in the first
place is because the arrest is someone
from marijuana which I'm like who cares
who cares right so I'm getting through
the store I'm like bro just let him out
who cares this is I like let go get her
money back let these guys free who cares
but it's getting deeper and then I find
out this dude's kidnapped on the cell
phone be like yo did anybody hear this
[ __ ] yo don't talk to anybody forget you
heard this [ __ ] [ __ ] and I'm like
you'll get this [ __ ] get him now
because now I'm invested again now I'm
like guess these [ __ ] if they
able to if they're about to do this [ __ ]
for this [ __ ] yeah they did some
other [ __ ] we gonna get today oh we go
we're gonna get to that I mean you
already there hey there let's go okay I
hope season eight doesn't let me down
let's go so she goes to her sergeant
her Sergeant goes to rosinski Sergeant
rosinski Sergeant calls him in and goes
what is this all about
the money don't worry about it Sarge we
got it covered I'm writing a supplement
report and the sergeant says stop
I don't know what you're talking about
but stop what you're doing
everybody did what was right when it
came to their attention by our suspect
who is now the victim of a theft
but these three folks
so our
rosinski Sergeant gets with his
supervision we started a criminal
investigation immediately
this all happens from last Monday last
Monday's when the lady made the initial
request for her money back
we do an investigation and our
detectives
and supervisors are simply the very best
did what they were supposed to do
when they saw something that wasn't
right they immediately investigated
and within five days of this being first
brought to our attention and a sorting
through and talking to the supervisors
and the peony and complete an
investigation on Friday night
we locked all three of these deputies up
now I can tell you I've been with the
Sheriff's Office my entire adult life
and from memory I can only remember two
other occasions
in almost 50 years
where we've arrested more than one
Deputy at a time and that was both of
those occasions were back in the 1970s
correct okay this is the first time ever
that we criminally charge three deputies
give them my two shots so basically what
they just didn't find the money
so they're just gonna pin them yeah but
also the evidence tampering as well
which is hiding the evidence which is I
think the big thing yeah because your
your tampering with the evidence that's
important for a case per se and we don't
know who the hell got the money yes yes
but more importantly it's like the way
that they try to finagle the evidence
itself which is what's the real issue
then they didn't send an issue with that
twofold oh first number one you know
obviously my initial reaction was like
whatever you love me but if you think
about creating public trust we all know
that if we stole 730 we got caught by
the cops it'd be a big thing so to let
these guys off with stealing 730 isn't
right because it sits the wrong
precedent you got to lead by example
consider you got those extra Powers
extra privileges extra responsibility so
I agree with it from a principal
standpoint I think that's where the
chief really has me in that regards
considering his whole speech
the second thing I think of is the only
reason these guys got caught is because
they're dumb as [ __ ] yeah because
they're stupid right
and he said it's like oh you know
this is um the only time we could really
remember capturing multiple people must
believe there's far more elaborate
well-covered well documented
um cover-ups or police operations in
terms of like stealing money stealing
drugs all this other stuff that's
happening that they'll never find out
about
they only caught this one because the
woman said hey I need my money back in
any lawyer through the evidence like
wait something's missing and the people
were stupid with the way that they went
about stuff hey [ __ ] don't tell nobody
goodbye
what
I'm half a brain and know how to cover
their tracks so
I don't want to [ __ ] on this whole thing
because I do think it's great that he
came up here and he was like very open
with everybody and said listen we're
making an example out of them though
honestly how much time are they really
gonna face how I don't really know but
you still need to give kudos and flowers
when it's due because at the end of the
day they're doing the right thing
um but in my head I'm thinking like it's
the [ __ ] we not talking about that
really matter yeah because we like me
personally I'm happy that this happened
in the way that he handled it and
everything and stuff it was really uh
straightforward we really thought when
he came in I thought it was going to be
a press conference no it was story time
yeah uh so but but he was very open
about it and very transparent with it
but I got mixed feelings so I'm happy
that that happened the way he handled it
but now it just proves what I thought
about the police when you have a backup
and when you have two officers that's
why we say that's why I say that all
cops are bad and I already told that to
some cops we had this discussion and I'm
saying if you're if you're there's
something I got I got got arrested but
cop pulled me over and everything and
stuff and we had this conversation when
I was talking to him about you know
you're a cop before you're black he
didn't like that shout outs to you Mr
Johnson it's the fourth time this guy
arrested me anyways that's different
because that's the story anyways
so and he was like saying no I don't
like what you're saying like yo listen
and his is is his partner went overboard
at some point saying some [ __ ] to me and
they went to the car for verify my ID
while we were having this conversation
and after we called out the car
after he got out the car his partner
came out I'm like see see what you did
there your partner you're going to tell
your partner he did wrong maybe you're
going to tell your partner he did wrong
later on you don't not gonna catch him
on the spot
when he goes overboard when he's not
shutting the [ __ ] up when he should shut
the [ __ ] up and just listen because
we're having an A and B conversation
right when you get to say something
that's very egregious and I have to
catch him back and that's what it is
basically if you see your partner do
something wrong you're not going to hold
him accountable right on the spot maybe
later on maybe the next day y'all
remember what you did I think what you
did was visit but the deed is already
done
you're not going to catch them up right
now or sometimes they're going to cover
his thing you're going to cover him with
[ __ ]
are you gonna cover him with [ __ ]
yeah at all we're we're right now we're
in an investigation and you know damn
well it's not true okay just to cover up
what he's saying because you know you I
get arrested for some [ __ ] right and
that's the reason why because no matter
what happened the fraternity of cops is
bigger than
whatever
even if you want to do the right thing
you can't be doing you you can't go
against that because you got people
looking at you wrong and stuff but
anyways all that to say that there's
that's a reason why it just proves what
I'm saying that yeah of course there's
gonna be some bad apples but the rest of
the apples most of the time don't say
[ __ ] now it's great that he's saying
[ __ ] he's talking about it but like Abba
says it's a [ __ ] that we're not
talking about that we should all the
people that are not filmed that are not
talked about that are actually a little
bit smarter than these three goobers the
dude that get off with a lot of things
and whenever we talk about it they're
like man we don't have evidence of yeah
you're gonna do it you're going to do an
investigation but you're gonna
investigate yourself unless it's a big
thing right unless I get hurt by the
police or whatever or not if it's not
that you're gonna investigate yourself
where is the trust so I'm glad that he
did what he did but yeah I'm still oh
I'm so iffy about it you know what I
think it is what you think it is I think
it's when you say all cops are bad
it just turns folks off kind of like
saying toxic masculinity I understand
yeah but it's not that all cops are bad
because even if they're good they
actually whenever when you think all
cops are bad I think it's like a it is a
shortcut it is a shortcut okay if you
use this I understand I understand what
I'm trying to say but I'm trying to
explain why I get it why they say that
but no they're not all bad but the It's
like because of a lot of forces and a
lot of things that can they cannot do
what they want to do even the ones the
ones that are good it's like a it's like
a it's like a drop in the ocean you know
I mean but no they're not but that's
what it is yeah the marketing of that is
very bad same as yeah
the investigation woman who went to her
Sergeant who got involved with the
internal affairs everybody got involved
in order to make sure she got her money
back so you saw how all of them turned
on those three right because he
basically said now we're gonna out to
him and then publicly do it on a
platform so maybe that's happening more
than we know maybe maybe we just don't
see it because not everybody's on
YouTube [ __ ] platforming but then
when cops are doing shady [ __ ] it's
always platformed or at least like what
we're hearing about it or seeing it
through videos in YouTube right when
they get caught yeah yeah like when a
cop gets fired they're probably not
gonna do a YouTube press conference all
the time right okay so Story Time people
yeah this [ __ ] got fired because
this is what he did nobody nobody's
gonna put all this because it looks bad
it just looks bad and they don't want
people to make it look bad cops already
have a bad rap it's also my suspicion is
that cops I think feel as though their
job is extremely difficult and they deal
with a lot of [ __ ] right and so they
understand like the intricacies of the
job
and when one of our people who they see
as a good person does something bad they
want to defend them because like damn we
deal with so much [ __ ] from the
outside world I'm not gonna throw you to
the Wolves because I always known you to
be solid so I'm gonna look over this one
thing not realizing there may be more
there you get what I'm saying so that's
also another possibility
um and also I think there's a very much
like us versus them mentality between
Fox and people yeah so they're like well
even if I saw this guy to the Wolves
they still gonna hate us so why am I
gonna do that right
um so I mean maybe that's just some of
the stuff that goes through but kudos to
this Chief uh to the sheriff I think um
I think this was interesting to hear
some of the behind the scenes it was
kind of refreshing so yeah it's good to
highlight good stuff I think as well and
uh
anything else oh yeah even though
Johnson's uh the fourth time of Johnson
Johnson arrest me he's one of the good
ones shout outs to you Johnson
are you resting all the time bro why
because I drive more than you yeah yeah
that's because you're Shifty and shaking
I'm what Shifty and Shady yeah that too
again